you've fought up a lot of amazing uh
battles in 2016 olympics
so you got
you beat the uh
let's see the world number four in the
quarterfinals
it's like a replay every single olympics
you're
all the people i got terrible draw
insane terrible draws and then you're
facing this is where i was like watching
this i'm like yeah he's screwed you face
the world number one the georgian and
by the way for people who don't know he
beat me
five times to my beating him once and
the one time i beat him was in london
and all other times he beat me he beat
me by phone
and not by like a little throw like he
threw me on my head
at one point we were in georgia
i'm fighting him in the final i go to my
teammate and i go guess what make sure
you watch this fight somebody's getting
thrown free pawn dismatching and this
ain't magical distance and about a
minute in i tried to take his head off
with a big koshy groom which was like a
head and arm
he caught me and then threw me on my
head and ended the match
so first of all we're watching the video
of you again standing next to the to the
guy leading up to your semi-final match
so here if you uh if you win this you're
guaranteed a medal yep uh but the
chances of you winning from my fan
perspective i was like god damn it
uh you and the rest of the world except
for me except for you wha what are you
saying you're talking to yourself here
what are you saying my name is travis
stevens i'm olympic champion i will not
be denied
that george is probably like what the
hell is this guy saying
was he talking to himself
so he was probably ultra confident yeah
had to be
the difference is
is i understood the last five times he
beat me
i was purposely trying to throw him not
beat him
i wanted to find out if i could
turns out i can't
but i don't need to throw him to beat
him
i need to know how to not lose
but you're still going for stuff here
but all of my attacks drag him to the
ground
they're never standing on my feet
which is a complete which is a
distinction that we talked about at the
very beginning right you have throws
where you're standing and throws where
you're dropping every time i try to
throw him standing
he throws me free pony picks me up and
he throws me on my head literally
so what i did is i just needed to get to
that last one minute mark which is what
he does mentally in his own judo where
he changes into a panic and just tries
to like do things that are
uncharacteristic
so you knew he's going to start
panicking here as you get as the match
draws so close and you both have a
paschito and actually we did we passed
the point where i went for broke and i
broke my rule
which one
i went for a crazy foot sweep
um
like epone switch
thing i can't remember what it's called
because it's not used that often
and he actually landed on top of me and
some people wanted it to be called epone
but he had actually
let go of the ghee and was looking for
the mat so he didn't have any control so
they didn't award him a point
yeah and here we go now we're getting
down into the see like he's getting
frustrated great yeah i love it
perfect second penalty no big deal we
just got to get to the one minute mark
that's all we got to do
so there's no panic here for you you're
not this i'm right where i need to be
and look it
now if you go back into this match
uh bye i would love for somebody to go
back and see how many times he did a
drop
write a poem say an aagi
probably never yeah so why is he doing
it now
because he panics and he changes his
judo at that one-minute mark
so look out look how much i kept that
grip yeah you kept
you have that grip this whole time you
have your left hand locking him down
walking him
down that he he you keep the grip as
he's throwing yeah which
do were you thinking choke as he drops
or no it's just kind of natural instinct
yeah because we drilled it i spent two
years drilling this transition and then
very so for people that don't do judo
jiu-jitsu
it's like really nice you keep
everything is nicely controlled to where
you're keeping that ghee under his chin
like it's really tight control like it's
very like your cog i guess is drilling
but you're cognizant of the position of
your wrist the whole time and you can
tell based on like
just years of doing it whether it's
under or it's not right you can just
feel the difference and it's probably
even if you wanted to stop that it's
very difficult because your whole time
it's like once it's under it's almost
impossible to stop
for people who practice jiu jitsu don't
practice judo one of the very annoying
things about
judo is in order to do
ghee chokes they have to be under the
chin yes
uh even though the kind of intense jokes
you do work just fine yeah over the chin
but
and the the kicker here and why we
practiced this choke
was because when you go back and watch
all of the other matches he always does
this tripod when i try to do arm locks
yeah which is typically what i would do
yeah and when i do that he ends up
sliding out and i end up falling off
right
so you step up here with the choke he
does a tripod where he sticks his button
to the air
and you
uh
dude what's the name of this choke
arrow
no but okay i mean when you do from like
from that position is is there a way
this entry into the bow and arrow i
guess because you're doing we we
referred to in judo as a british
strangle which when they when they're in
that turtle position and you do that
rolling
cool
and here
when you go into that you can fall off
of him like you said if you're going for
an arm bar but here literally
because you have it under the chin
really well there's just a nice control
and i've already planned on it being on
his chin that's why i've hooked the arm
yeah right it's already starting to go
straight probably this choke in the
early stages like a few frames before
feels like
it uh
like you're safe it's fine like like the
head will slip out or something like
that yeah and that's why my left knee is
up by his shoulder
to keep that pressure down so that he
can't posture it up
when did you know you have this oh i
work right here
i
i actually panicked
um
right about here
was maybe his head could come out my
hand i tore the muscle in my palm
because i was pulling so hard that i'm
like
he may not tap
yeah like is he is my hand just gonna
give out
beforehand and there he is we're right
on this edge right
yeah so like if we roll a little bit
outside and i still don't have it like
that ref could stop it yeah and then i
felt him tapping and
oh the that
he is um he's heartbroken i felt
surprised
there it is
the relief olympic olympic final
and he knew
he knew he lost an olympic medal right
there
because he already knew
that the japanese guy was going to be
his bronze
that he never beats
see the
but also he probably in his head was
confident that he'd be in the final
correct and so like this he almost is
surprised
yeah
it's not supposed to happen this way and
it's the second time it's happened
and that's how you became an olympic
medalist man that must be a great
feeling
that must be a great feeling right here
just like all the years of injuries all
of it
as as fans that watch this too it's like
holy [ __ ] he actually did it that's a
packed stadium too
not one empty seat
oh man
so uh
i mean what were you thinking here
i'm just focused on the next match yeah
it took me maybe
like a minute or so to like decompress
and then like get back to like my normal
state for the final
so the the final
is against the uh
the russian here what can you say about
your mindset
you're saying the exact same same thing
travis stevens olympic champion
i will not be denied
because i had felt like in london and
throughout the years i felt like
i kept getting robbed so i made sure in
my mantra to add that little bit at the
end to reassure myself that like
they are not going to control the
outcome of today
i'm going to control the outcome what
did you know about the russian
everything
um
and i i honestly i thought i'd win the
olympics right now and i still do think
that today just like
mentally when you think about it that
i've won like
yeah he threw me
but it was like a one in a million
chance that that worked for him
like come on
so it's not like you feel lucky to be in
the final it's like
you you can't remember i'm
i'm anticipating the goal like i'm i'm
past that
there's a confidence in the way you're
moving the way you're yeah like i have
his sleeve he's not breaking it like
still walking him down still going
forward like
um
i knew exactly how i was going to beat
him
and i developed the plan because when i
was getting ready for
rio we brought in a lot of the top
japanese players that weren't invited to
the camp for the national team
to boston so i had four people three of
them were on the national team one of
them had won
the universities in japan all at 81
kilos i only got thrown once during camp
for a month oh
like i was
i was ready
i just
i [ __ ] slipped
where does it happen
right when he threw me so if you let
this play out really quick
there's a point right here where i'm
going to come around his back
and i'm kind of going to just
yokosoteme which means like a lateral
drop and i'm just going to bring him
down to the floor which isn't a throw
right here yeah it's more of like a a
takedown right i'm trying to get him to
the ground because i want to burn him he
doesn't do any waza yeah so i'm just
going to keep burning him and you can
see that like
i get really close here he just went a
little too far
to his side during this exchange
and like he's running
oh my god he
he's very wiry for an 81 kg player yeah
there's not much like muscle on him
but he uses his length and his leverage
very well and you can see like i'm
really burning the clock here like
i'm owning these exchanges more than i'm
owning the tachiwaza ones the ones on
our feet so you weren't trying to
necessarily like submit him here or
like really hard or like
pin him you're trying to break him a bit
i'm doing both um i'm being overly
physical
um
[Music]
and to a lot of the bjj people who are
watching this like
they're like oh well i would have done
this i would have done that you've got
to think like
if that referee who's reffing the judo
side of it looks at it for a couple
seconds and it's like
uh he's not really moving yeah they'll
stop it
yeah so you're uh like you understand
judo yeah what's called nawaz or grand
work like well you because you're really
showing it to the ref yes you have to
show movement and progression
that hurt the forehead like see i threw
that hand in there kind of hard
ripping it across his face just because
the i gotta i gotta tell you there's a
calm well no he does look a little a
little broken
but
the the russians have like this calmness
they're pretty good at well don't forget
they've competed like this for a long
time yeah it's all he knows
and this is where i lose it see how my
knee hit the ground yeah my knee wasn't
supposed to touch the ground yeah
i was supposed to sit to my hip to bring
him down
something happened where my knee touched
yeah and
it didn't happen in the first one it
just happened there
it's like that
we never should have been in that
predicament yeah
and that's that's one of the things
where
when you're looking at
you know sports for anybody who's trying
to improve
you have to when you're when you're
trying to improve you've really got to
ignore
the ends of the spectrums right the
the oopsies
and the they got lucky
and you only focus on the middle like
the technique i was doing was perfectly
sound
but it just happened that the one oopsy
happened on the stage it shouldn't have
happened on and there's no
there's no amount of drilling that will
ever
like
prevent that from happening and that's
just the the that's sports that's sports
especially olympics especially judo when
it's like one yeah
oopsie can just be your that's it
that's it you know it really requires
and you have to wrap your head around
the idea of like if you want the ability
to beat these people and throw these
people like you got to be willing to get
thrown yourself yeah
like this isn't boxing there's no like
i'm going to stand in a place where he
can't hit me and i can hit him
because we have the ghee and because
they can grab it they have just as much
ability to throw you as you them
so how'd you feel here
how long was the duration of you feeling
upset that you didn't get the gold
versus never felt it never felt it
just
because he didn't beat me right right
it's an important distinction because
when i'm training and when i'm competing
like i understand that i take risks
and i accept those consequences that's
why i take them
that's a consequence
that's not him being the better judo
player that
dominated a match and i didn't have an
answer and then he threw me
then i would be a little upset
like when you're tired and somebody's
coming at you and like you can't do
anything about it that's a shitty
feeling yeah
you know and that wasn't this fun and
that wasn't this
like i accept
losing when it's
when it's my fault
well that was a hell of a story man so
from 2008
just the sheer number of injuries the
weight cuts
all of that the wanting to quit
the the doubts
i'm sure you did not get like the fans
probably started disappearing somewhere
between the second and the third
olympics like the support
from it did judo within the united
states and just everybody you know
the usoc tried to cut all my funding in
and say nah you're too old yeah
so through all of that to win the medal
i mean
that's what the olympics is about is is
there some like when you look back does
that seem like another person is this
like another lifetime ago or like that's
a hell of an accomplishment how do you
feel about the whole thing
it's a it's an interesting kind of
predicament because there's like those
cookie cutter answers about how proud
you are and how grateful you are but
at the end of the day it's not who you
are
so that that skill set and that
mentality that
you know it took to accomplish that
that's who you are
and so
this was just a stepping stone in in who
i am
so it's in the past to me
like there's no shrine in my house that
has like an olympic medal in it i can't
remember last time i looked at it
so you're saying like the the
all the stories the skills along the way
that's like you right now sitting here
is the shrine
yeah the who you become along the
journey is really what the prize is
right like when you think about
any of them most of the people that
you know go through that depression
after the games
it's because
that is their shrine like that is who
they've identified as that is who
they've told the world the community
their friends their family that's how
they've identified
i've identified as the person who
perseveres overcomes
and accepts challenges
so like i all those things are just like
you know putting a suitcase off to the
side and i'm on to the next great
chapter thing that i'm trying to do
and it's
it's both sad and cool that um
very few people in the world get to to
experience what it's like to be you i
mean this level
of having gone through that yeah journey
everyone has the opportunity to
yeah
i mean i've done a few
uh
difficult things in my life but i gotta
tell you weight cuts and sauna
um
and i would tell people right now who
are listening like don't go through that
and i think a lot of wrestlers a lot of
young
judo players a lot of long young like
just combat sports people where
weight classes are a thing
they almost take a sense of pride like
when i hear them talking about like oh
how much weight do you have to cut if
you have to cut a pound more it's like
you've accomplished more like you're
tougher yeah like you're not
like there's no there's no trophies for
that
you whatever the reason had a job to do
and you got it done and that
that is truly inspiring no matter how
hard
that there's a big deep lesson to learn
from that
then you start getting to the specifics
of whether you should wake up or not but
if we don't then most of the great
things we have in this world we wouldn't
have the reason we have many other great
things is because people did that weight
cut
the equivalent of the way cut for
whatever the discipline man
there's a difference between
having to do it because you have to and
you get through it yeah then setting
yourself up to do that because you think
it's the cool thing or the thing you're
supposed to be doing in order to be
successful yeah there are plenty of like
two-time olympic medalists i probably
could have been a two-time olympic
medalist had i not
cut that much weight i probably would
have multiple world medals had i not cut
that much weight because my body
wouldn't have been that broken yeah
there's always the other side of it so
just when you're looking at it like
i just hear it in like young kids even
some of my own like when you hear them
talk about like where their weights at
they almost take a sense of pride on how
much they have to lose because they hear
stories like this
and it's like
that's not the takeaway i did it because
i had to i was put in a situation where
like
i may not have gone to this game that i
moved up to 90 kilos because i wouldn't
have had time to grow into the division
and then you get the job done and then
you get the job done you're right
there's a
it's just a very important difference in
that yeah also with sleep
uh that's what people talk to me about
there should not be any glorification of
not sleeping yes there should not be a
glorification of cutting weight but if
that's
on the way
to your whatever
is that fire inside you that you know
needs to get done like the job at hand
if
you need to sacrifice in some of those
ways you get the job done yes yeah and
uh the wake up is an interesting one
because it's different i mean you you
could speak to this
there's different sports in which the
weight is more important than others and
there's different levels to this game i
think at the level you operated in that
was probably essential yeah like those
huge games change completely from 81kg
to 90kg it's a huge weight jump it's
it's first of all it's weight but then
the strategy it's like so much changes
the height and all those kinds of things
the physical like people don't
understand it but the physical size of a
90 kilo judo player versus the physical
size of an 81 kilo cheeto player it's
like putting a human in a human like
there's enough
space that's not like
you know you could stand next to your
friend who's 180 pounds and you could be
160 and you guys could look identical
yeah it is different when both the 90
kilo 100 kilo and 81 kilo both have six
percent body fat
and they're cutting into the class
it almost feels like there's more
variety at 90 kilo because some of them
are lengthy and tall yeah and some short
and stocky stocky it's like 81 is more
uniform which i but then the you know
the flip side of that is the this is
what i like in jiu jitsu again amateur
uh competing against bigger guys like i
love that more i like i like cutting
weight just so i'm slim like that's when
i feel the best with the same thing that
you mentioned but like i love going
against
200 220 that because in jiu jitsu the
the weight doesn't get amplified in the
sport like the weight is just the weight
right if you can
if you can leg press 220 and you can
bench 220 then yeah you can train with a
guy who's 220 that's that's easy they're
not going to hurt you and i mean there's
there is a truth that
you know lightweights and middleweights
in jiu jitsu and the same is true for
judo it's just like a lot more of them
that means if you want to be
is it you're just competing at a higher
level
so like
there's much more variety of games the
level is much higher so you're taking on
a bigger challenge even if you're like
um have a weight advantage so those are
all decisions you have to kind of make
and certainly jiu-jitsu people that are
way cutting are silly i mean that's
that's the natural beginner thing to do
is to
feel um the way the nervousness about
competition expresses itself is through
the desire to be
as light as possible which is the
totally wrong desire to have right like
when you
when you look at me now i'm probably
like 230
right
but i probably have the strength of a 70
kilo
judo player yeah right the weight
doesn't really
do much yeah
i mean you have the same thing with
wrestling yeah the skinny the skinny
guys the skinny you that we're looking
at there just the amount of power in
that person yeah it's fascinating
because it doesn't look like you have
some muscle but it doesn't look but i
felt the power of some of those people
yeah uh it's scary yeah
it's different that's the best way i can
describe it it's like scary it's like oh
[ __ ] again it's the food chain you're
not at the top of the future yeah
that's the that's the natural feeling
when you go with some judo people
you